breaking news of the brutal killing of
Professor Joseph
weer what's this about PL object to the
head I'm
sorry I don't understand none of
it we'll be buring the electrodes in the
memory centers the temporal and paral
[Music]
loes you sck away I'm doing a clinical
trial I for a lot of stuff
my doctor says I got to keep my mind
active Joseph weider's murder doesn't
make
sense really went down I ain't no killer
make it right or I'm
dead he tells me he didn't do
it
Richard he was the crime scene why is
that what about Laura she's got no
address no social media nothing
there was always people visiting the
house it's it's
strange just like everyone from we's
life is now a ghost what are you trying
to say
all if we' put away the wrong guy this
is a chance for us to make that
right WR I forget about all
this people kill for a whole lot of
different
reasons you may not have memory but you
do have quite the
[Music]
imagination